[Music]
foreign
here we will showcase the 15 biggest
aquatic monsters from the Star Wars
Universe let's get to it
at 15 we have the mamako this creature
only seen in brief in the season 2
episode 11 of the Mandalorian are
carnivorous monsters from the planet
called truss and its Estuary Moon they
appear as a gigantic circular mouths
with full of teeth kind of like a kraken
from the Pirates of the Caribbean one of
the species was kept in captivity by
quaran Boatman who fed it on a regular
basis this mamako attempted to devour
grogu alive at one point of time but was
quickly assaulted by The mandalorians
Who Saved grogu
at 14 we have the nos monster these were
gigantic aquatic animals that live in
the planet called utpal in its
freshwater lakes Subterranean rivers and
sinkholes the animals had massive front
fins that they used to battle across
their habitats and storm on any prey
that ventured into the monsters hunting
areas and layers nice monsters also
possess big green eyes that let them see
underwater as well as a tail that they
swing as a weapon they did appear in a
deleted scene in the Revenge of the Sith
number 13 the Iowa first seen in the
attack of the Clones the second episode
of Star Wars they were seen on the ocean
world of kamino these were classified as
citations that are also as air whales
these creatures who could swim and fly
used their wing tips to propel
themselves through either environments
water and the air the large beak-like
mouths contain baleen which are used to
filter Krill from The Saltwater oceans
they and the caminoans adapted at the
same time to the ocean world when the
ice caps melted and drowned the land
masses
number 12 the quasimao The quasim Mao
were massive aquatic slugs that lurked
at the bottom of the planet called
rhodius and its marshes their skin was a
key distinguishing characteristic with
bright bioluminescent patterns and also
had a considerable resilience to deflect
Blaster balls and Fire And even certain
missiles these massive animals possess
huge Jaws that when open could swallow
an entire humanoid whole these creatures
are primarily aquatic but also have
amphibious traits as well
number 11 the OPC killer these were also
called the gooberfish and they are
massive aquatic creatures found in the
Seas of the planet Naboo they contain
evolutionary traits from many other
species combined together including a
strong armor jaws with two rows of fangs
and purple prehensile chunks which they
can use to ingest little food quickly or
to catch and drag large animals into
their jaws the organism moved by sucking
up water and expelled via minuscule
vents on his backs it would approach its
victim and drag it into its mouth with
its long slimy purple tongue and was
very terrified to look at
number 10 the hydride Medusa alright so
these creatures aren't really fully
organic but are part machine like a
cyborg the cockrodons created these
enormous jellyfish cyborgs with armor
and other cybernetic upgrades on their
homework called kakaris for use in
battle they were virtually impenetrable
with blasters and lightsabers doing no
harm to them at one point of time the
Republic and mon calamari forces were
forced to retreat after suffering severe
casualties after facing these creatures
and number 9 we have the camera Dawn Sea
Dragon this deep sea monster was a
gigantic aquatic reptile like animal
also known as a saberjal during the
earlier years of the Galactic Empire the
Gamora John dragons resided in the
waters of Camino surrounding typical
City the creature has three pairs of
flippers and a lengthy tail that it used
to navigate the seas in quest for food
its mouth was shaped like a pointed
snout and was loaded with sharp teeth it
also had a smooth dorsal shell as well
number eight the sea Leviathan this was
a monster of immense length and Mars
with significantly better Dimensions
than either the Aquatic or the Terrain
Armored Transport used by the people of
Star Wars as sharp generals around its
huge Mall packed with the rows of sharp
fangs on the seal leviathan's mouth it
also had blister Parts which function as
Life Energy siphons as well as the seal
leviathan's primaries mode of assault it
was an aquatic Beast particularly
developed for living and the Deep oceans
of the outer ring planet called Dark by
a scientists of doth crates one sits
order
number 7 the color clawfish this color
clawfish was one of the biggest animals
discovered in naboo's oceans the color's
body was long and flat with two rows of
bioluminescent nodules on either side
used to attract prey it was the second
largest predator on Naboo larger than
the OPC killer which it aids and second
only to the Sando Aqua monster in size
its head was huge and crocodile-like
with a long snout stocked Eyes Two
mandibles and a row of poisonous teeth
for subduing prey number six The Raven
act this was the first creature that was
seen in the Mandalorian series a native
animal of the planet called pagadon it
lived underneath the ice sheet that
covered the planet's frigid Seas it was
a huge animal that had large dusks on
its mouth similar to that of a walrus
but its size would even dwarf a blue
whale the ravenak was also very highly
aggressive and highly predatorial
attacking anything on site as it is the
apex predator of that world number 5 the
Dinosaur turtle seen in the Mandalorian
Series this Dinosaur turtle was a
massive non-sentian reptile the Beast
was known to be very vicious and attack
both the mandalorians as well as chomped
down on a giant flying creature called a
raptor the Dinosaur turtle walked on all
four legs and had a long tail its skin
was almost impenetrable to blast the
fire except for the larger fighter
aircraft called the N1 its shell was
also likewise resistant to Thermal
grenade detonations but couldn't survive
Torpedoes it lived mostly underwater but
also walk on land without any problems
number four the geonosian Hydra many
systems have Legends of huge
multi-headed dragons and such species do
exist and especially in the Geonosis
Bleak and Barren surface geonosian
hydras forage over Geonosis deserts
utilizing their muscular legs and
several heads to scale the messes and
bottles that dot the landscape in order
to obtain access to the hives of the
geonosians their favorite meal these
hydras although seem to be terrestrial
were amphibious and also lived primarily
beneath Geonosis small and scan Seas
number three the mythosol seen in the
Mandalorian series these are enormous
underwater as well as amphibious
creatures discovered on the Outer Rim
world called Mandalore they were
allegedly tamed and ridden by Mandalore
the great and other ancient mandalorians
way back in the past but they were
thought to have died out and went
extinct long before the Mandalorian
cataclysm yet at least one mythosaur
survived and thrived in the Living
Waters during the age of the new
Republic and it was the same one
discovered by Bo Katan number two the
Sandu Aqua monster the Sando Echo
monster was the biggest carnivorous
aquatic creature in naboo's waters
little was known about these enormous
creatures and they mostly exist only in
Legends or in folklore it has a long
synonymy body that resembled a feline
with hind legs for Mobility on the ocean
floor and also have large thin claws for
propulsion through the waters it was
also poorly streamlined and lack a
covering of fat or blubber so you would
think that it won't be aquatic nature
however it seemed perfectly fine even in
the Deep trenches
and number one the rockner seen in the
animated Star Wars resistance they were
a type of identical sea monster from the
planet called castellon rockner had four
eyes six tentacles and a green blue
pattern on its skin its pupils were
formed like an hourglass adults were
sustainably larger and bigger than
juveniles whereas the juvenile is
handled in the arms of a humanoid an
adult or a specimen of her mother is
huge enough to demolish an entire
aircraft refueling station's platform
they are as of now the biggest aquatic
monsters from Star Wars
so those are the 15 biggest Star Wars
aquatic monsters so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care guys
[Music]